Direct interaction, where for example, you use the mouse to control or
influence what's happening in the scene, is handled using events. An event is
generated by the system whenever a user presses a key or uses the mouse. There
are other kinds of events, but these two, keyboard and mouse input, are the
main ones we care about in Three.js. Well, I should mention there's also a
touch interface that's somewhat similar to the mouse interface, so that you can
interact with scenes on a smart phone, or other touch-sensitive display. You
can ignore any and all events or can listen for any you wish. Here's code for
listening to a mouse click event, specifically mouse down, which means when the
mouse is first clicked. If you want to wait until the mouse button was
released, you would listen for mouse up. The addListener event takes a function
name as an input. Whenever the mouse button is clicked this function is called.
This code defines the function called on mouse down. This preventDefault line
is optional. It makes your program not past the mouse event on up to the page
running your javascript program. I usually don't use this call. The rest of
this function is up to you. A mouse or key click could modify an object, start
an animation, you name it. Enough talk. What follows is an example of using the
mouse down event to perform picking. You are orbiting around a bunch of blocks.
Try clicking on a block as you move past them.